hello everybody my name is Stefan wah
I'm a senior producer on this game thief
and I would like to give you a couple of
tips to be really a perfect master thief
first of all even before starting your
game please pay attention in the menu to
all the options we gave you because it's
really really important we we gave you
so many options to make sure that you
are going to customize the game like you
really want to play it also another big
and very important tips is be curious
you must be curious and when you play
this game you must look around there is
tons of Secrets puzzle tons of objects
to find and if you're really really
curious you should have a good time with
with this game another thing that you
have to know it's depending how you
would like to play this game we're going
to give you secondary objectives so
console go in your journal and check the
objective for for example if you are a
very an aggressive player maybe a
secondary objective would be to have for
example for edge shot and if you do it
during the mission we're going to give
you some gold to reward you this game
will give you a lot of background story
because a thief game is not a thief game
if we don't give you all these
information so while the game you're
going to have a lot of documents
newspaper to read to learn more about
the city about the the citizen and also
through this documentation you will find
very important information for example
maybe you need a specific combination
for safe yes by reading these documents
we are going to give you that type of
information so be curious again and pay
attention to this and finally obviously
how in this game shadow is your best
friend
so if you really want to feel powerful
stay in the shadow pay attention
just listen conversation read any
document but stay in the shadow in the
shadow you are really really powerful
nobody will see you
I'm really really proud about this game
we worked very hard to give you very
very cool experience and now February 25
the game will be yours so thank you for
watching and I'm looking forward to
receive your feedback thanks
[Music]